in fact the the show's getting ready to
start up again
this month what's your skin walker ranch
there's a show about skating oh god dude
they've got some you've seen this guy
he's a he's a phd scientist he's working
there
they're trying to figure out why this
place has all these weird energies
and every time someone tries to dig
something bad happens
one of the guys got hit in the head with
something and he said it actually
separated his
scalp from his skull and they believe it
was microwave energy that did it
so somebody was shooting microwave
energy at him when he was digging this
hole out there
making his scalp separate from his skull
and that's what happened to all those
cows they were skinned with no blood i
don't understand bingo what was going on
yet they looked at some video
and there's like some something in the
air that's above one of the cows when it
drops over and it can't get up
and it just hangs oh there's video of it
dude like i said it's getting ready to
start back up they were
they brought in ground penetrating radar
and found something that was about 4 200
feet
long about 20 feet under the ground so
they tried to drill down to it
and as soon as they tried to drill down
to it the ground started shaking and the
guy said hey check out that telephone
pole then the police
was on a show this is on the show the
name of the show uh skin walker ranch
the show is called it's on the history
channel the history channel it starts up
may 5th
okay dude it's great it's got so much
this
these are scientists they're trying to
figure out what's going on they're not
they're telling you what you're looking
at they're just saying hey that's
something what is it i wonder how much
of it is like hyper sensationalized just
for tv and how much if it's actually
legit
well i'm sure that it's like it's like
everything else man i mean you always in
the
the you go into a commercial break with
not telling them what the answer was to
the
because that guy bigelow just did a
podcast with joe rogan and i watched it
because i'm like super into these ufos
he's there he didn't say one thing about
skinwalker
oh yeah that's crazy dude that's crazy
because he's on he's in the he's in the
video he's on the
i was honestly kind of disappointed with
that guy john bigelow what he was
talking about i mean he's like
he wasn't very lucid i'll use the word
drip he's a drip no it didn't seem like
that it
seemed like he was just kind of like
not that not there yeah it seemed like
it just seemed like
he wasn't as informed as you would like
him to be or he did when you see him in
this
like he was when he first got there and
they
they brought on the two new scientists
and he's they started talking about
digging
and he goes oh no there's not going to
be any digging here every time we start
digging something bad happens
yeah and so he started with all the
things because we're not going to talk
about it right now
because i don't know where you guys are
at on this we're going to look at a few
other things
and the scientists that was there
actually went down
to uh this area where this
this energy is coming up out of the
ground and the energy got so heavy he
actually got sick to his stomach
he said i don't know what's coming up
three if this is electromagnetics that's
coming up through here but he got
deathly ill
all the phone batteries went dead they
couldn't keep they couldn't keep a drone
in the sky
they keep seeing something in the sky so
all these odd phenomenas going on
and what he's they're trying to do now
is they're putting cameras up in just
about every square inch of the property
so they cover everything and trying to
figure out what's going on right
so and it kind of ended last season
on a note where they were again they had
dug down about 20 feet and hit something
because dude
whatever's down there i can't get
through it let me drill down any farther
and like i said the ground started
shaking because they looked up he goes
hey check out that telephone pole the
telephone pole was swaying back and
forth
what so he didn't know and you've seen
this guy on tv before
once you see him in this flick you've
seen it before so he brings
a certain amount of reality to the show
like he's really looking for what it is
he's like i'm not telling you it's
anything until i see what it is
right right and because the guy that
owned the ranch before bigelow
um said that he actually had material
that was
from extraterrestrial craft that he has
locked in a warehouse
what was his name
dang i can't think of his name right now
but he he when he sold it to bigelow
he told them what was going on with the
place so whether it's you know again is
this a spiritual place because of the
earth
you know is this an earth movement thing
is it is this related to native
americans
that live there at one point in time
because well it isn't even i want to see
it to be
i have to see this [ __ ] to believe it
see the skinwalker the whole idea of the
skinwalker
is this is an individual that can morph
into animals
and he's kind of a spirit the navajo
really fear him
but for whatever reason it's just
attached to this again
obviously the name skin walker ranch and
has gotten
the strangest coverage because
everybody tries to go in there look at
something but they can't really
do anything because the batteries go
dead the cameras die or they and once
the camera went there they couldn't
record the event that was taking place
but it's gonna be back on i think was
may 4th which is a sunday may 5th
and it's going to uh like i said it's
again
all it's going to do is validate a lot
of what we're talking about today
there's something
bigger that's going on right but the
problem is you can't really validate it
because it's a tv show you know oh for
sure i mean it's like so great it's so
entertaining and it sounds like you want
to [ __ ] believe it it's so fun to
watch and it's so fun to talk about
but just because it's because of the
fact it's a [ __ ] tv show
sure you can't validate it you're like
oh it's a [ __ ] tv actually it's the
opposite
because it's a tv show now you can
actually dismiss it sure
so he like i said they've done some
things that are interesting i mean they
brought some power meters on and look at
the look at the
this energy that's coming in and when
they triangulated it
he goes it's coming from above us it's
not on the ground it's coming from above
us
so they were trying to figure out how
high it went up so they actually made
this balloon and
attached this emp device to it that
could uh
uh measure the amount of uh uh
electromagnetic pulse was coming down
yeah and got it to a certain point then
it burned up and dropped out of the sky
so like i said the whole show is full of
obviously it's something interesting
going on
at the ranch whether it's you know ufo
related or if it's some sort of anomaly
that the
you know uh that the property does
because it's maybe
more iron than not right i don't know
but it's
it's like i say man it's coming back out
there's definitely some weird
[ __ ] happening there oh definitely some
odd things that are going on
for me again that's really kind of the
draw for it
um you know but now say explain that
again explain that again with the guy
with the guy who said that's [ __ ]
i'm gonna [ __ ] dig anyway
yeah thomas winterton is one of the guys
on the skinwalker ranch that
actually works he's a ranch hand and as
he got hired there
um each of the ranch hands were told
listen when you come onto the property
there's no digging
and he was like why can't we dig and the
guy's like cause we don't want you
digging and he's like well i don't
understand why we can't
i don't want you digging on the property
they didn't tell them there was anything
spooky about it didn't tell us
anything ufo associated they said i
don't care what you do in the property
but no digging
so he was putting up some fence posts
and after he
i guess was with this thing for about 20
minutes to half an hour he's like this
is [ __ ] i'm gonna go get the bobcat
real quick and i'm gonna drill a hole
down here and put this post in the
ground
so he went back and got it came back up
started to
dig a hole in the ground and got this
excruciating pain in the back of his
head
and he said it was it was nauseated he
didn't feel good it was almost immediate
so he left um got back home realized
that there was something bigger going on
so they brought to the hospital
yeah and when they brought me the house
they took an x-ray of a skull and
literally on the
right hand back side of his skull was a
knot but they couldn't figure out what
that knot was from well then as they
x-rayed it
the scalp was actually coming off of the
skull
and had looked like almost like an area
where fluid had filled up
and the doctor was looking i've never
seen this before how did this happen
he's like i was on this field digging
and all of a sudden i got a pain in the
back of my head and here i am
what's up world you just watched a clip
from one of our exclusive
patreon episodes that's right you can
get weekly
pure uncut content straight from the
jungles of columbia if you want to watch
the full episode make sure you go to
patreon.comconcretevideos
peace
i